Why do conflicts and division occur more
>> conflict and
>> division?
>> Conflict and division. Conflict and
division occur more frequently among
Muslim and Muslim than between Muslim
and non-Muslim.
Does this indicate a fer Muslim to
foster brotherhood?
Thank you.
The sister asked the question that why
does conflict and division
appear more amongst Muslims and Muslims
rather than Muslims and non-Muslims?
I do agree to a certain extent what the
sister is saying is right not totally
but I do agree and she's asking why do
Muslims fight among themselves when we
believe in the same Quran, the same
prophet, one Allah. Why do we fight
against amongst ourselves? The reason is
because lack of knowledge, ignorance.
Because they don't read the Quran. If
they read the Quran and you implement
the Quran, the Muslims will be totally
united. Unfortunately, we don't read the
Quran with understanding. We may read
the Arabic with our understanding. So,
if we read the Quran with understanding
and implement on it, we'll be united.
Unfortunately, someone gives a lecture
which may not be part of the Quran. It
may not be part of the hadith and that
is the reason there are differing views.
If there are differing you use then okay
my myust says this myust says this. So
there's a fight. Allah gives the
solution in chapter 4 verse number 59 I
quoted I gave the reference
and the verse continues
obey Allah and obey the messenger and
those
who have been given the authority like
the scholars but the verse doesn't end
there. It continues. If they differ, go
back to Allah line is rasool. If they
differ,
you go back to Allah's rasool. Who is
our which is our scale of checking? If
they differ, our scale of checking is
the glorious Quran and the sai. So if
they differ, you ask both the where is
your reference in the Quran? What does
the Quran say? What is mentioned in the
hadith? Let's analyze. So if Quran gives
the solution, obey Allah, obey the
messenger, obey those people who have
knowledge.
But if they differ, go back to Allah and
his. So we don't go back to Allah and
that's a problem. If you go back to
Allah and inshallah, we'll be more
united and the differences will not be
there. All done for the west.